pseudo elements there's more to your
HTML than meets the eye there are parts
of the UI that you can style with CSS
that don't actually exist in your HTML
markup take for example a form input
that has some placeholder text the
placeholder value is defined as an
attribute on the element so how do we
get ahold of the placeholder to style it
the answer is we target a pseudo element
in our CSS they always have a double
colon to distinguish them from pseudo
classes the difference is that a pseudo
element represents an actual part of the
Dom whereas a pseudo class represents
the state of an element based on the
user's interaction with it pseudo
elements can make your code much more
efficient take for example this HTML
where the first letter in each paragraph
is being wrapped in a span so it can be
styled a far more efficient way to solve
this problem is by targeting the first
letter on the paragraph element the end
result is much cleaner semantic HTML
that's cool but by far the most powerful
pseudo elements are before and after
many but not all HTML elements can have
content inserted before or after their
inner content handled entirely from your
CSS code for example we can target
before and provide an empty string as
the content property now that we've
targeted this element you'll notice that
it shows up in the browser's inspector
we can style this element as if it were
an empty span or div in our HTML and
that can be very useful for creating
advanced animations without polluting
your HTML markup imagine we have a big
unordered list and before each list item
we have an emoji character instead of
duplicating it in the markup we can
simply add it as the content property to
the before selector and once again we're
left with code that is far more
maintainable there's a few other pseudo
elements that you should know about
selection allows you to change the
background and color of highlighted text
in some browsers like chrome but not
Firefox you can customize the scroll bar
on scrollable elements before using the
pseudo element always check for browser
compatibility ones like spelling error
might sound cool but they don't really
have any browser support yet this has
been pseudo elements in 100 seconds make
sure to also check out pseudo classes
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one
you